today on the matt welsh show the biden
administration has said that american
families will have to bear the cost of
defending ukraine against russia why
should we have to bear that cost because
we have to defend our values overseas
they say but whose values and what
values we'll talk about all that today
also the supreme court will decide
whether a web designer has the right to
refuse to make wedding announcements for
a same-sex wedding and the sponsors of
that so-called don't say gay bill in
florida have started to buckle under
left-wing pressure unfortunately plus
another ufo sighting proving once again
definitively that aliens walk among us
in their daily cancellation we'll deal
with the unintentionally hilarious
efforts of the women's march to turn
student debt
into a women's rights issue all of that
and more today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
the pro-life movement must maintain its
momentum now more than ever and what
better way to help than by supporting
the charities and causes that you care
about even if the supreme court were to
strike down roe v wade abortion will
still exist in america it's still going
to be legal in in many states across the
country charity mobile is the pro-life
phone company and it's still so
important that you support the pro-life
cause and pro-life companies they
partner with you to automatically
support the pro-life pro-family charity
of your choice with five percent of your
monthly plan price and have sent
millions of dollars to charities so far
there's plenty of other perks as well
like new activations and eligible
accounts get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping when you
mention offer code walsh trading mobile
makes it easy to switch you can keep
your existing phone and you may even be
able to keep to you can keep your
existing phone number rather and you
might be able to keep your existing
phone as well but if you need a new
phone no problem charity mobile has a
variety of options from the latest 5g
phones to the low-cost smartphones and
basic phones as well all of their
monthly plans include unlimited domestic
minutes and messages which can be shared
by up to eight lines on a family plan no
contracts no termination fees and no
risk with a 30-day guarantee there's
also great live customer service as well
so switch charity mobile and support the
causes you care about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mention offer
code walsh
up until this point i think it's safe to
assume that you had never spent one
second of your life thinking about
ukraine or worrying about who controls
the different regions of it
it's not that you're callous or
apathetic it's just that you're a finite
being limited by both time and space and
so you're naturally most concerned with
the things happening closest to you
countries are fighting all over the
globe in various ways factions are at
war with one another all over the place
land being taken claimed reclaimed
are you supposed to have an opinion
about all of those conflicts
are you supposed to take a side
maybe there are people fighting over
something in botswana right now or
zambia or wherever else
but you don't even bother to check
because if there is a fight happening in
those places it's not your fight
now this again is not cruel disregard
for the suffering of others it's rather
a lack of mental emotional and physical
resources
you could only be so many places at once
you can only care about so many things
at once
it's also a matter of priorities you are
loyal first and foremost to your family
and your community your country
that is your realm of interest
your sphere of influence
that's what's been given to you to care
for and help protect
but now in an instant
out of nowhere
the powers that be in in your country
are telling you
that you should care very much about
ukraine
it is indeed now your responsibility to
care about the suffering of the
ukrainian people you're told
how could you abandon them in their time
of need
you are tied to them by spiritual bonds
that you've just now been made aware of
and which require you to care about
their circumstances even as you're
allowed to continue not thinking much at
all about the circumstances of people in
botswana or zambia or bolivia or
uzbekistan or nigeria
or even afghanistan now
that last country was supposed to matter
deeply to you for the last 20 years but
now it's not supposed to matter at all
nobody could quite explain why it should
have mattered before or why it shouldn't
matter now if it did matter before but
you're required to stand still and let
the conveyor belt take you to the next
destination
don't ask any questions
because now it's all about ukraine
you are allowed to spend every second of
your life up until now not caring about
that country
not ever thinking about it ever
but today
today you must care deeply you must be
willing to sacrifice anything for its
sake
and if you don't
if you commit the sin of feeling the
same way about ukraine as you felt
yesterday and every day before that then
you're a despicable traitor
you're treasonous scum
you should be arrested and shot or maybe
just shot why bother with the arrest
russia is moving into some regions of
ukraine that you know nothing about
never you've never been there you don't
know what they look like you don't know
anything about them but putin claims
that the people in those regions want
him there
ukraine says that's not true our
government and the media also say that
it isn't true now you have no way of
knowing for sure how true it is or isn't
but your patriotic duty allegedly is to
simply believe whatever distilled
version of a complex geopolitical issue
you happen to hear on cnn
if you fail to believe it or if you even
ask for more information in regards to
it
you are again a traitor
i mean if you ask a simple question like
when when putin says ah well they want
us there and you say uh do they i mean
do we know that they don't
even that question makes you a traitor
you can't ask it
who are you to ask questions like that
president biden spoke to the nation
yesterday and uh managed to be rambling
and meandering even though he only spoke
for 10 minutes and didn't take any
questions
of the parts of his speech which were
intelligible amid all of the drunken
dementia riddled slurring and stuttering
this perhaps was the most important
biden said that there will be costs that
your family will have to bear for the
sake of ukraine
listen defending freedom will have cost
for us as well and here at home
we need to be honest about that
but as we will do but as we do this
i'm going to take robust action to make
sure the pain of our sanctions is
targeted at a russian economy not ours
now you might point out that gas prices
were already high that's true but it's a
fact that the administration hopes you
forget and most people probably will
forget it as we're all like the guy in
memento with a memory that resets itself
every 45 minutes
but from here forward
every bad thing happening in our country
will be because of the ukraine crisis
and thus because of russia and putin
cbs news got the memo and published this
headline this morning here's the
headline
the u.s economy has been hit with
increased gas prices inflation and
supply chain issues
due to the ukraine crisis
now sure we had increased gas prices
inflation and supply chain issues last
month
and the month before that and before
that and before that and before that
before that but it turns out that all of
those problems were caused by the things
that putin is doing right now
he's more dangerous than we thought
apparently he has a time machine too but
even if the administration plays this
game it's still true that our
involvement in the ukraine crisis which
is only really a crisis because we've
chosen to treat it as one
will come with a cost
and it'll be a cause primarily paid by
you and by me and our families not joe
biden
if this does escalate to a full-scale
war
that'll be another cost paid exclusively
by us
and not by the ones who caused the war
raises another important question
why should we have to pay any cost at
all
why should my family be forced to suffer
any consequences whatsoever
or make any sacrifices whatsoever for
ukraine
now i ask this question sincerely by the
way
it's not rhetorical i mean unlike most
pundits and everybody else on social
media
i'm not pretending to be an expert on
the russia ukraine conflict just because
it's the thing that's happening right
now in the news cycle
my focus and interest and area of study
is our culture the things happening in
our country the state of our own society
so i admit to knowing very little about
ukraine which puts me in the same boat
as almost everybody else talking about
the topic even if most of the rest of
them won't admit that they don't know
anything about it
so i'm willing to believe that there
might be theoretically some valid
national security reason to involve
ourselves in the ukraine situation
that's the only reason why i would ever
support our involvement our government i
contend should be exclusively focused on
serving and protecting our people
nobody else's that's their only job it
has no other job
but events overseas can of course
hypothetically affect us in direct and
significant ways forcing us to inject
ourselves into the middle of something
like this i mean that's possible
and so i ask not rhetorically
why should we care about this
how does the fate of the contested
regions in ukraine
directly and personally impact
my family and your family
how is our security directly at stake
here
and as to whatever actions we're taking
now or will take in the future
how do they make us safer and help us
thrive
i don't want to know how they make
ukrainians safer or help them thrive
i don't really care about that i want to
know about us
because that's what matters to me as an
american
it's a good question and one that the
people in charge must answer
if they can't answer it or won't answer
it
then we have to draw our own conclusions
as it happens a reporter at the white
house briefing yesterday
did ask this very question he asked jenn
pasake
why americans should have to bear any
cost for the sake of ukrainian
sovereignty
i mean how do you make that sales pitch
how do you tell american families who
are already hurting from all of these
things
that they have to hurt more now
for ukrainian sovereignty
what does that have to do with us
here was the answer
well i think what hopefully the american
people who are tuning into this or have
been tuning into this we'll see is that
the president of the united states and
in his entire uh national security
apparatus have been rallying the world
and standing up against the efforts of
russia to invade and take and carve out
a chunk of another country for their own
and that is the world is standing with
the united states against the actions of
president putin now why does that matter
i realize that's what you're asking me
why does that matter to the american
people that should matter because that
is a fundamental value that we as a
country stand up
for and we stand up against that type of
action that goes back to world war ii uh
and uh and we have repeatedly throughout
history been leaders in the world in
rallying support for any efforts to
seize a territory from another country
what the when the president spoke to the
american people last week it was very
important to him to be very direct and
clear and straightforward with them
about what this could mean
as we looked to what the impact of an
invasion could mean and also what the
impact of sanctions could mean and the
fact that standing up for values
is not without cost including in this
case
well there you have it
the white house doesn't even pretend
that american families are somehow at
risk because of putin's actions in
ukraine
if they if that was the case and if they
could make that case they would have
made it
that's the strongest case
they don't even pretend that our
involvement is to protect and defend our
own people they say that this is about
standing up for values
which is the same justification given
for every bad and disastrous conflict
we've involved ourselves in for the last
several decades
we have to stand for values
but what values
the value that says no country should
ever invade another country how is that
of value
there are again invasions and incursions
and conflicts all over the globe
everywhere all the time
do our values stipulate that we have to
play referee in all of those disputes
and i have to ask who appointed us
referee anyway
what right do we have to assume that
role especially since we've been known
to do plenty of invading ourselves
no that can't be the value so what is it
what values are we supposedly fighting
for is it the value of freedom
well what is freedom
our government is run by people who
think freedom includes the mass
slaughter of infants
to them we have to kill 60 million
babies for freedom that's freedom
they think freedom must sometimes
involve shutting down thousands of
private businesses by force closing up
churches forcing kids to wear muzzles
for two years in a row
that's their idea of freedom
they believe in the kind of freedom that
includes chemically castrating 11 year
old boys
freedom for them might might also
involve censoring unsafe political
opinions
they believe in the kind of freedom that
has turned our cities into crime
infested wastelands
is that the kind of freedom that we now
want to export overseas
is that what we're out there defending
so valiantly
see the uh we must defend our values
thing was always foolish but now it's
also foolish but as well incoherent
because how can we quote unquote defend
our quote unquote values when we don't
share any values
what's this our values stuff
speak for yourself pasake
i don't have any of your values
we have no values in common at all none
the buy administration just hired a drag
queen bdsm dog fetishist to help run our
energy policy
is that another of the values that we
have to defend
as far as they're concerned it is
crt gender ideology racism
anti-christian anti-tradition anti-human
these are their values
i don't just not share them
i hate those values
i am at war against those values
and now they want me and all the rest of
us to go to war in defense of values
that we detest
they call for our loyalty of fidelity
after years spent treating us like scum
and labeling us domestic terrorists
and they expect us to just go along
well they're in for a rude awakening
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well you know with four kids at home
plus a dog who hates my guts uh it's
there's constantly dirt in the house
it's it and that's why you always got to
stay on top of it and that's why we use
a my house naturally it's clean did you
know that you can get a hospital grade
cleaning product that won't leave
harmful chemicals on all of your
services introducing naturally it's
clean a home cleaning company dedicated
to providing the most effective cleaning
products for your home while reducing
the use of harmful chemicals as well
their secret powerful plant-based
enzymes nature solution to cleaning
naturally it's clean has safer chemistry
formulas to clean every area of your
home from the bathroom to your hardwood
floors to your kitchen all of their
products are manufactured right here in
the usa and they offer two-day free
shipping direct to your door and they're
also again safe which is great too when
you have kids because they're constantly
getting into everything
and that's why you need this product try
them for yourself right now my listeners
can get their hands on the naturally
it's clean daily wire essential kit
stocked with four great products for
fifteen percent off simply visit
naturallyitsclean.com matt and use promo
code matt
try try out these incredible cleaning
products in your home today for 15 off
by visiting naturallyitsclean.com
well i am i am fighting my own battle
today um also courageously fighting for
my life because i have another cold that
i'm dealing with um it's not coveted
though i didn't take a test so you know
who really knows um but as always for me
my colds all concentrate in the throat
these are the only symptoms i ever get
just the sore throat which is great
because i talk for a living
but my kids are to blame for this as
always
you know because they're constantly
bringing disease into the house they're
just vectors of disease or little petri
dishes that you have in your house all
the time
um and that's one of the many reasons
why i wasn't going to panic over kovid
and never did because you know i
couldn't have panicked even if i wanted
to i don't know how any parent could
because kids are so disease infested and
germy
that you just have to learn to live with
it and accept it you just you get kind
of you get used to it
they're going to be bringing all kinds
of exotic diseases into the house and
you just you know it's going to happen
and you and you live with it
there's no other way to function
so this latest thing i got for my
two-year-old
and i know the exact moment that i
contracted i know when i got it
um
because it was the moment that she
leaned in to tell me a secret
like leaned in directly face to face and
then proceeded to cough right in my face
point blank range i could like i could
feel the particles the cold virus
particles going up my nose and infecting
me right in that moment
and the secret by the way
was it wasn't even a good secret and it
never is with kids
because she came over and said daddy ah
secret and so okay what's your secret
and then and then
first thing
right in my face
and then
i saw a cow in my womb
room she saw a cow in her room that's
what that was the secret
which first of all if there was a cow in
your room why are we keeping it a secret
and second you're totally full of it i
guarantee there was no cow
fact check on that
misleading
more source is needed
not worth getting sick over
all right let's um
before we move on from ukraine i wanted
to check in and i think this this is
worthy of being the top headline for us
today in the five headlines i want to
check in with a voice of reason on the
ukraine subject uh someone who
i think we were all kind of waiting and
like i've already i've already said it
i don't know a whole lot about about the
issue myself and most people don't and
so we're waiting for voices of authority
people who
know what they're talking about and are
very well read and have studied this
subject we're waiting for them to kind
of uh you know guide us give us a little
bit of guidance and finally yesterday we
got that listen to this
the phone is not hacked it's really me i
actually want to say a lot of things but
i'm just going to mind my business
because
sometimes i feel like i have such a big
platform that if i say if i don't say
the right things i might get killed but
i'm really not on nato's side i'm really
not in russian side
i'm actually in the citizen side because
at the end of the day the world is
having a crisis right now there's
inflation not only in america but
everywhere in the world
it's really hard to get um
the economy back up
there is so much shipments and
embarkments backed up
china is not really messing with us so a
lot of things are behind a lot of goods
are behind and this [ __ ] just made it
way more complicated so i'm just really
annoyed by this and i really wish that
all world leaders right now just really
come with a logical conclusion but
whatever
i mean she raises some good points uh as
she says so so much shipments and
embarkments backed up
um i don't know i'm not sure if those
are even words but
uh and china's not really messing with
us she points out i mean you could say
that they are kind of messing with us
and that they unleashed a virus on the
world
they killed five million people you know
they kind of messed with us that way but
um either way that's that's her uh
that's her take and you know what that
is
what i'll say about it at least
is that it is at least as coherent
and meaningful as anything we've heard
from the bio administration about this
issue
that actually made
mo i'm not going to say it made a lot of
sense but it made more sense
comparatively than uh than the clip we
played
of jen pasake
saying that we have to we have to get
involved for our values
so
you know who's whose side are you gonna
take cardi b or jen pasake those are the
only two sides available i'm afraid okay
this one the wall street journal says
the supreme court said tuesday it would
consider whether a colorado website
designer
had a first amendment right to refuse to
produce same-sex wedding announcements
which is the latest clash between lgbt
and religious rights
since its landmark 2015 decision
extending marriage rights to same-sex
couples the high court has moved
cautiously in carving out constitutional
exemptions for organizations business
owners opposed to those rights
last year the justice decided that a
catholic foster service agency receiving
city funding was entitled to turn away
same-sex couples despite local laws
prohibiting such discrimination
the decision was based however on the
court's own reading of philadelphia's
fair practices ordinances and its
contract with catholic social services
rather than broad constitutional
principles
um
the court has yet to rule squarely as to
whose rights the lgbt communities or
religious conservatives must yield when
they directly
conflict the colorado case granted
tuesday to be arguing the court's next
term and likely decided by june 2023
suggests the justices may be ready to
address that issue
so there's also the masterpiece cake
shop
case which is was also out of colorado
and there's a reason why all these cases
are coming out of colorado because the
colorado whatever they call it their
equal rights or the human rights
commission whatever or welding a name
they give to it but they've been on this
campaign for years now to seek out any
christian business owners in their state
and and punish them put them out of
business
um
and it's often time very oftentimes very
targeted very intentional
you know uh jack phillips over a
masterpiece cake shop
there's been this targeted effort to
take him down there's
we we know for a fact i mean there was a
a
transgender person who
went to jack phillips in colorado a
couple years ago
and said they wanted a a um he wanted a
cake to celebrate his gender transition
a gender transition cake because that's
a thing now
well it's not really a thing but but
this guy invented it
because he wanted to entrap jack
phillips and so that's the kind of thing
going on
um
is that what happened here you know i
don't really know i'm not sure
um
but one way or another
you know same sex couple wanted um
wedding announcements
and this web designer said well i you
know i can't do that because
that means that i'm in some ways i'm i
am directly promoting i mean i'm
advertising a same-sex wedding and
that's against my religion i can't do it
um
that's why this is very different okay
although these these sorts of things are
always conflated this is not the same
thing as um as a say a restaurant
putting a sign out out front saying no
gays allowed
okay that's that's a different sort of
refusing of service
not the same thing
because in this case the web designer
didn't say oh i can't do any work for
for gay people if you're a gay person
i'm not gonna i can't be involved with
you that's not what was said
okay this is not a um
discrimination quote unquote against
individuals
this is just a particular sort of
service that i cannot provide
i can make announcements for various
different things i i but an announcement
for a same-sex wedding
that's just something that i don't
provide i don't do that
and really her her reasons for not doing
it shouldn't even matter
she's the business owner
um if she doesn't want to
do this if she doesn't want to associate
herself with that then that should be it
this is this is not only a matter of
free speech right it's also a matter of
and also of course freedom of religion
but it's also a matter of freedom of
association
which is the very freedom
that the gay rights side has hinged you
know the right to gay marriage on it's
freedom of association
well does a business owner not also have
that same freedom
to decide who they're going to associate
with and particularly what services they
want associated with them
and you open up the floodgates and uh
and
present a lot of extra questions
if you say oh yeah well we can we can
force you to make wedding announcements
for a same-sex wedding
what if there's you know we we could all
think of all kinds of different types of
events
that a person a business owner might not
want to be associated with for one
reason or another
are they not allowed to make those kinds
of
determinations now
now in the wall street journal article
it says that this is a case um
where that the court has to rule on
where we're weighing the lgbt
community's rights against religious
conservatives rights
and as they put it um which when these
rights directly conflict which rights
have to yield to the other
well
this leads to the question of just like
we asked in the opening
when we talk about freedom what do you
mean by that we have to go overseas and
defend freedom
well i need you to tell me what you mean
what do you mean when you say freedom
because we are not working with shared
definitions when it comes to any of
these words that is very clear by now
so the same question comes
with with rights what do you mean by
rights human rights
because if if the idea of human rights
means anything if it's coherent at all
then it would seem to me that they can't
really conflict
if there appears to be a conflict where
you have one
right claim against another right
claimant and one has to supersede the
other one has to yield so the other can
be asserted if that's happening i think
that's a pretty good indication
that we have a misconception about what
rights are
and that one or both of these rights
claims are false
because our human rights are supposed to
be embedded they're supposed to be
natural they're supposed to be inherent
to us as human beings
which means that they should not
constantly be bumping into each other
and causing all these kinds of conflicts
if there is this sort of conflict then
that would seem to indicate that we're
we have a misapprehension about what
rights are
and that misapprehension is pretty
obvious here
is this the lgbt community's rights up
against religious conservatives rights
no
because as far as the lgbt community
goes
their rights are not at stake here
what what right is at stake exactly
what right is being infringed upon
for the business owner we know what the
rights are it's pretty clear freedom of
speech
you know ken uh
making a wedding announcement is a form
of speech so if you if that speech can
be compelled by law then it's hard to
say you have freedom of speech so your
right to freedom of speech is at stake
if you could be compelled by law to do
something that directly conflicts with
your religious beliefs then your right
to religious liberties at stake
and if you could be compelled by law to
associate with something or with people
you'll want to associate with then um
then your right to freedom of
association's at stake
so it's very clear on that side where
the right claim comes in but for the
lgbt community what right are we talking
about
your right to wedding announcements
and even if there was a right to wedding
announcements which i don't you know i
don't see that enumerated anywhere
um i don't know where that right comes
from is that a god-given right that god
imbue us all with the inherent natural
right to wedding announcements
but even if you have that right
somehow
well
by no means is that right being
infringed upon or taken away or even
significantly interfered with if one
person one business owner says oh i
don't want to make those announcements
because there are dozens of other places
you can go to get the exact same thing
made
and i guarantee for the same price
probably
so if there is some sort of right to
wedding announcements that's that's not
at stake here you can still go you go
anywhere else
and i think that's what a normal and
decent person would do
you know if you want to get announced
announcements made for some kind of
event and a business owner says hey
listen
i i just i don't believe in this and i
i'm sorry but i can't make i can't i
can't be a part of this
as it's just a decent adult the correct
response is okay i'll find somewhere
else
but then to go to the government and say
no no i want you to force them
they don't want to be involved but i
want you to force them to be involved
well why can't you go to any of these
places over here no no because i i want
this person they said they don't want me
and now i want them
that makes you a child
that's that's narcissism in on steroids
so there's no right what is the right
exactly
that's at stake for the lgbt community
if
the supreme court says that oh yeah this
business owner has the right to not make
those wedding announcements
does that mean that no um same-sex
couple ever again will be able to get
wedding announcements made is are we
worried about that happening
i
if that is your concern then i can just
tell you that that is certainly not
going to happen
and this is also the one of the um
inherent contradictions on the gay
rights side because
um on on one hand
they we we are constantly told by lgbt
activists
that the kind of anti-gay marriage side
the uh you know belief in quote-unquote
traditional marriage
which i don't really like that
qualification of traditional um
because what you call traditional
marriage i just say that is marriage by
definition but regardless they would say
that
you know the belief in in quote-unquote
traditional marriage um
that is uh it's a
it's you're like a dinosaur if you if
you still stand by that
you're far outnumbered you're way on the
fringes you're a wacky fringe
right-wing whatever
that's what they say
but then at the same time they say that
if the supreme court doesn't force
christian christian business owners to
do business with same-sex couples for
same-sex weddings then uh the next thing
you know
no same-sex couple will ever be able to
do business anywhere ever again
because although this is this is a
fringe wacky dinosaur view
apparently all the business owners in
america are just waiting for the
opportunity they're waiting for the
supreme court to give them the go-ahead
so they can put the you know no gays
allowed sign up on the window
well which is it
choose elaine is what i would say all
right
this is an update from the washington
examiner i think a rather unfortunate
update
it says a florida lawmaker withdrew a
proposed amendment tuesday that would
require schools to notify parents
of their children's sexual orientation
as part of a larger and highly
controversial bill that would bar
schools from discussing sexual
orientation with students
well gender identity sexual orientation
with elementary school students is an
important detail to add in there
joe harding a representative in the
florida state house filed the amendment
last week seeking to add it to the
so-called don't say gay bill that has
garnered significant national attention
the amendment would have required
schools of school officials to inform a
student's parents within six weeks if
their child tells the school they have a
non-straight sexual orientation
but now it has been withdrawn
two lawsuits have been filed in recent
months after two separate public schools
orchestrated gender transitions for
students who expressed gender dysphoria
without notifying the student's parents
and that by the way is one of the
reasons why this amendment was added
and it's a reason why the amendment
should stay in there
my only problem with the amendment the
only thing that makes it outrageous and
offensive to me
is that the schools were given six weeks
to tell the
parents no i don't want not six weeks
how about like six minutes
there should be
no atta there should be no time elapsing
between when the school finds out some
intimate detail about my children and
they tell me
that should be immediate
like not not not six days certainly not
six weeks
you tell me right away
because it's my right to know because
it's my child it's not your child it's
mine
uh and that's why the amendment should
stay in there so it's quite
disappointing that it was that it was
taken out
and uh this kind of sends the message
that oh okay well
actually schools do have the right to
keep uh secrets with kids
and not just not just any secrets but
secrets of a sexual nature
schools are allowed to you know
just because the school knows this uh
really important detail about your child
doesn't mean they have to tell you
because that's what we're talking about
here again this is
this was the amendment never required
that schools sit down
and um start interrogating the kids okay
we're not talking about waterboarding or
something to find out what their sexual
orientation is
no the whole point of the bill is to say
that you should not be having those
conversations with elementary school
students it's none of your damn business
it's not appropriate
but
if you do happen to find out some
important information about a child
their parents ought to know there
shouldn't be any information about a
child
you know about like a nine-year-old
that all of his friends in school know
and that even the adults in the school
know but the parents don't
really there should be any information
like that nothing there should be no
details like that
especially when it comes to anything of
a sexual nature
but that amendment was taken out
unfortunately
all right this is from the new york post
we gotta cover this because you know i
like these stories alien hunters were
left stunned after a bulging triangle
ufo was filmed lurking over a major city
for two hours
the unusual object was spotted prowling
the skies of islamabad in broad daylight
by an extraterrestrial enthusiast
um
so it was there for two hours let's take
a look at the video here we have the
video
it's just sitting there
do we get does it zoom in at all
i wanted to do something let's see can
we get a zoom in
okay well kind of it looks like a a
smudge on the camera oh it's moving
around a little bit
it's quite quite amazing isn't it
i mean it's definitely a naked eye i can
hardly now see it's definitely something
there is something in the sky there's a
some sort of
a naked eye object
i can't say anything at all
i should have looked at this footage
before we played it on the show shut up
okay well
well i'm convinced
i mean what else could that be besides
i mean in fairness i could think of like
10 other things it could be but
going through the list of options
as i always say
the alien option is we have to agree at
least the most exciting yep and the most
interesting so it's what i choose to
believe
all right that's enough of that
does it get okay i was expecting to zoom
in a little bit more
i was expecting it to zoom in and then
you see the little green hand poke out
the window and wave that's what i was
expecting
have yet to see footage that compelling
but still pretty i mean look
there's an here here's let's just
summarize this there's an object in the
sky
no doubt about that
nobody knows what the it's unidentified
uh they're for aliens
i rest my case all right one other thing
so a couple days ago
a basketball game between uh michigan
and wisconsin got a little bit heated
uh michigan was was losing the game by a
large margin but towards the end
michigan's coach juwan howard
felt that the other team was kind of
like running up the score
and being on
like i think they called you know they
were winning they're going to win the
games only a few seconds left and then
uh uh
wisconsin they like called a timeout and
so they're running up the score
and so he was upset about that
and his way of communicating his
feelings was to slap one of the other
coaches in the face
it wasn't quite that direct there was an
altercation there was an exchange of
words and then howard slapped the guy so
we have the footage let's play some of
this footage here
you see the one coach you know they're
yelling at each other because he's
saying look you're being mean to me i
don't like
you're being super mean
and then the other the other guy jumps
in too says no you're the mean one
you're the mean one and then up slap
right in the face
yeah
these are the coaches by the way acting
that way so look
after that howard um the coach who
slapped the other coach
was suspended just five games and given
i think a forty thousand dollar fine
which is relatively minor you know for
for for these guys a pretty light
penalty and so i was initially torn on
this because on the one hand
you're a grown man you're a coach you're
supposed to be a role model
and uh you're you're you know you're
taking care of
you have your team as kids basically i
mean college kids and so you're supposed
to be setting a good example and here
you are getting into a slap fight after
the game on the other hand
you know i actually think we tend to get
a little bit too bent out of shape about
guys getting rough with each other
especially the context of sports
um this is how dudes settle differences
sometimes we tend to express our anger
in a more physical way
and uh yeah i don't think that should be
such a big deal a little tussle no
reason for it to be a breaking news
scandal
ultimately though i think you have to
penalize him because you know when you
balance everything out
he did get into a physical fight with
another coach in the middle of the game
but
so that's that's kind of my take on the
whole situation but then the left-wing
media got to work and here was the
headline from dead spin
when it comes to juwan howard and greg
gard who's the other coach
why is the black coach the only one
suspended when the white coach started
it
now to be clear the black coach smacked
a guy
and only was suspended for five games
it's about as light as the penalty could
really be i mean five games
you could easily make if you want to
take it here which which is not where i
would take it
it's not my decision to take it in the
the racial direction but if you're going
to take it there you could easily make
the case that his race helped him if
anything
because just imagine for a second if the
races were reversed i mean imagine if
the footage is a white coach
slapping a
black coach across the face
i mean brian flores would file a lawsuit
over that and he's he doesn't even play
he's not even in basketball he's in he's
in the nfl
there'd be lawsuits over that probably
and uh and we'd hear all about the you
know systemic racism and everything
imagine the dead spit i mean this
they're able to make this kind of
headline when it's the black coach slap
of the white coach now think about what
the dead spin headline is if it's the
white coach slap in the back black coach
uh but you almost have to admire it i
mean they that's the thing about the
left is that they always stay on message
no matter what
black coach slaps a white coach
in reality race has nothing to do with
it whatsoever these are just two guys
who got who got you know are taking the
game way too seriously and they started
fighting
but on the left they always stay on
message stay on the narrative
you have to admire it
maybe not admire but respect it a little
bit i guess let's get now to our comment
section
[Music]
to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
all right uh dailywire.com sweetbaby
comments if you want to leave a video
comment we've got a couple of those
let's uh start with clip nine
hey what's up it's your boy gibberish
here uh just witnessed a cart fly across
the parking lot uh i'm at target right
now
but i'm not gonna go get it because i'm
in cleveland and uh you get robbed like
every 10 minutes here if you step out of
your car so yeah that carts on its own
now uh if it hits someone
not a problem of mine
i just put one away the other day i have
a video of that
but
yeah that card's staying where it is
so
not in cleveland not getting them there
so spg for life but i'm sure i'm banned
so
thank you
well you are banned of course and this
is your guilty conscience
why else would
you feel the need to
let me know about this you're trying to
justify something you know isn't right
all that is needed for evil to flourish
is for good men to do nothing remember
that gibberish remember that
let's play the next one
hey there matt walsh with the daily wire
here
good to see you
sweet baby gang for life i'll see you
monday tune in
okay so that guy's supposed to look like
me i guess is that the idea
he's got a beard and glasses like every
single person who has a beard and
glasses now i'm always told oh he looks
just like you
there's probably millions of people with
beards and glasses it's not that
distinctive of a tree he i mean i could
see the result you know what he looks
like he is um
try to put my finger on he's he he's
like a combination of me
and uh roy from the office
if me and roy from the off you know
pam's boyfriend
if me and roy from the office had a baby
it would be that guy
so this is the origin story maybe of the
the sweet baby from the sweet baby gang
logo
it's quite a horrifying gorgeous story
not a movie you want to see i guarantee
you that
um let's see scott allison says if i had
a daughter at a science camp and a
biological male identifying as they then
shared a room
they would soon identify as patient 457
an icu ward um
that's the appropriate response and as
always with these kinds of stories you
have to ask the question of where are
the dads even in the news clip that we
played yesterday from this story
uh parents speaking out about the fact
that they're
you know they sent their 10 year old
daughters off to a science camp
and then they come home and find out
that that adult male counselors were sh
were were bunking with them having
slumber parties with these uh with these
little girls
and yeah we were told parents were
speaking out about it except that all
the parents in the news clip were all
the moms
where are the dads exactly
very good question
uh danielle says sexuality should not be
discussed or taught at any age in school
now tolerance acceptance and
non-bullying no matter your sexual
preference or gender identity has been
and is in force and should be
but that's completely different than
actively teaching it
um
let kids be kids they should learn that
there is much more to personality
lifestyle than your gender
sexuality
i'm only going to disagree with you
danielle because i don't think that
tolerance and acceptance should be
taught or enforced either
you know
because then the questions are like what
are we tolerating exactly
why are we tolerating that
and acceptance is a whole other level
who decides what we're supposed to
accept and why
these are all moral claims and moral
judgments
and you as a public school teacher
that's not your job
you know to moralize
and to kind of impose your own moral
view of the world
onto kids
now it's not your job it's not why
anybody sends their kids to public
school you know parents send their kids
to public school thinking that they're
going to get naively thinking they're
going to get just a basic academic
education
so it's not your job it is also
inevitable
that the lessons being taught to kids
will be wrapped up in a moral
world view
um but that doesn't make it okay
all right let's see what else we got
joshua says i think you're wrong on
ukraine we should be willing for
full-scale war
we learned in the last two world wars if
you ignore dictators they'll keep
conquering until someone stops them
either we stop rushing now or we'll have
world war iii later
you want a world war ignoring this is
how you get it
okay see joshua i
appreciate at least that you're trying
to make some kind of national security
based argument for why we should get
involved
um so
you're on the right track you're trying
to make the right kind of argument
i just don't find the argument
compelling because it's actually not an
argument it's just an assertion
what you're saying is
uh we let putin take over ukraine next
thing you know world war iii well you
got to connect those dots for me
okay cause it's like step one
putin takes over ukraine
and then down here like step 10 is world
war three but i need to know steps two
through nine you gotta fill in that how
does that work
i mean are you suggesting that
putin takes over ukraine and then keeps
going and next thing you know he's
trying to invade the united states and
take us over too is is that your concern
well i don't know but you have to
explain that to me
because i have i have heard this
from plenty of
at least on um you know as far as the
buy administration they're still talking
about we have to defend our values and
so on and so forth
but when it comes to the peanut gallery
online most of them you know you're
hearing a lot about well it'll be world
war iii he's going to take over the
world and all this kind of stuff but
you've got to got to flesh that out a
little bit more because i don't find it
terribly convincing
diana says i don't agree that parents
have the right to know their child's
sexual orientation that's creepy
and if the students who are outed do end
up being abused or kicked out
that would be horrible
so it's creepy for
a parent
to know their child you find that to be
i hope you're not a parent yourself
diana with that kind of attitude
that that's creepy you wanna you want to
understand and know your child that's
that's creepy
now if you're using some sort of mind
reading device to do it then uh maybe
i'll
agree that that might be creepy but
no in this case it's just you know what
the mind reading device is it's
you should be told
information about your child that other
people already know
so what we're talking about here is
a child has quote unquote come out at
school
and um their friends know it and the
teachers know it
everybody knows it
but should should the parents be the one
group that does not know this
information about the kid
i would say the creepy thing is when
everyone has this information
about a child's
you know sexuality and the parents do
not they're the only ones that are cut
out of it
there's just here's a general rule of
thumb
there's never a good
non-creepy reason
for an adult
to want to keep these kinds of secrets
with a child away from the parents
uh let's see john says
you aren't giving the animal bill of
rights comments or a fair shake here
animals that are in captivity by humans
aren't able to freely live however suits
them best non-pets on the streets are
owed nothing because they're they aren't
being forced into captivity
pets you force into your home are owed
at life equal to the potential top
quality they could achieve on their own
life on the streets is probably far more
miserable than a mediocre pet owner
offers their pets but it's kind of a
dumb straw man to make the comparison
between the two in the way that you did
okay so they they're owed a life equal
to the potential quality they could
achieve on their own
so you mean that they should eat once
every four days
uh sleep out in the cold in the rain be
infested with ticks and parasites live
about six years and then die miserably
when their corpses are consumed by ants
and crows
because that's the life they would lead
on their own
that's the life of a wild animal
forced into captivity that's that's how
you think of domestic domesticated dogs
and cats
it's not forced into captivity they're
not our slaves they don't do anything
this is not forced labor
most of these they just sit around all
day we have elevated these animals to
the status of of animal royalty like
animal celebrities
so if a dog complains it's like that's
like when lady gaga complained about
being too famous it's just it's not
especially compared to what everyone
else is going through compared to what
other animals are going through you got
it easy you got it made in the shade
literally
and and this also raises the the
question we go back to the question of
rights and we don't have time to get
into all of it but but although they
have the right to do this they've where
you says who what where do animals
derive their their rights from exactly
where are those enumerated
philosophical question though we don't
have time to get into right now you know
something about the daily wire is we're
constantly getting bigger we're
constantly growing every day we we hire
five new people it seems like and you
can see for yourself how much we're
growing how much we got going on with
our binge-worthy new docu-series the
enemy within featuring acclaimed
journalists and expert at national
threads lee smith smith uncovers a
political coup orchestrated by america's
ruling elites to generate their own
wealth and power at the expense of the
american people's safety and freedom the
second episode goes deep into the biden
family's ties to chinese business and
how joe biden his administration and his
family have used their positions of
power for personal gain at the expense
of american security here's the trailer
check it out
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within you're trying to
obscure responsibility for four million
people dying around the world senator
paul you do not know what you are
talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness
that match the cruelty and wickedness
of medieval torturers and executioners
dianne feinstein
had a chinese spy as her driver for 20
years we're not talking about one person
infiltrating senior levels at the cia or
the white house we're talking about an
entire elite class
throughout the political corporate
academic cultural and media
establishment my name is lee smith i've
been a journalist for more than 30 years
this is the most astonishing espionage
and infiltration operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
[Music]
well all episodes of the enemy within
are streaming now exclusively at the
daily wire so if you're not a member
now's the time to change that head to
dailywire.com subscribe to join us today
you know there's no better place for a
grand meeting of the minds than sitting
down over a cup of coffee and letting
conversation flow and nobody knows that
better than ben shapiro in his new show
the search he'll be taking you to his
favorite local spots to let you in on a
secret where the conversation goes when
the camera isn't rolling the second
episode of the search will feature his
very good friend highly lauded historian
niel ferguson it's an excellent
conversation and i highly recommend you
check it out the episode releases
tomorrow thursday the 24th it will be
exclusive to daily wire members so if
you're not a currently a member head to
dailywire.com subscribe to join today
well as my status within the lgbtq plus
community continues to grow uh so does
the cultural importance of my
best-selling lgbtq plus children's book
johnny the walrus this is why i was
invited on to dr phil as uh you know as
an expert in the field to discuss these
most important issues with other experts
who were apparently not such experts
because they couldn't even tell me what
a woman was but if you haven't seen it
yet i highly recommend you check it out
even more importantly if you have not
picked up a copy of my best-selling
children's book you should do so
immediately it's sold out in 48 hours
when it was released but don't worry
more copies are on on the way and
they're going to ship very soon so
reserve johnny the walrus now on amazon
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well i felt like canceling uh feminists
again today one of my favorite pastimes
and initially i thought i'd cancel them
for this according to espn quote
players from the united states women's
national team have settled their law
their class action equal pay lawsuit
against the u.s soccer federation for a
total of 24 million dollars the ussf has
also committed to providing an equal
rate of pay going forward for the
women's and men's national teams in all
friendlies and tournaments including the
world cup the issue of world cup bonuses
had long been a point of contention uh
for the players quote from uh megan
rapido she says there's no real justice
in this other than this never happening
again with the settlement of the working
conditions and this settlement which is
contingent upon a cba that will have
equal pay going forward there's no other
way to look at it than just a monumental
win for women's sports and women's
soccer in particular
okay so female soccer players will now
get equal pay
something that if they didn't have it
before it was probably because nobody
cares about women's soccer
it's a simple economic explanation it's
the same thing that explains why wnba
players make three dollars an hour while
nba players make three million dollars
an hour i might be slightly exaggerating
the pay scales there but the point is
that the nba has lots of fans whether it
should or not while nobody has ever
actually seen a wnba game like nobody
has
there's actually a lively philosophical
debate about whether or not the wnba
even technically exists
given how little interest there is in it
women's soccer for its part has two
strikes against it one soccer two
women's
although i suppose i should be grateful
that female athletes have finally
achieved equal pay
right in time for the men to take over
and that really is the greatest
absurdity here
because these liberal female athletes
are celebrating this great victory for
women's sports even as women's sports
has effectively ceased to exist
and that's i think worthy of its own
cancellation if not for this at the 11th
hour
the women's march has swooped in to
claim the cancelled title for itself
playing the gender card on a different
topic but just as absurdly the women's
march official account on twitter
tweeted this quote
women hold 929 billion dollars in
student debt two-thirds of the nation's
entire 1.7 trillion dollar student debt
load
this is a gender justice issue
potus canceled student debt and put an
end to this crisis
okay
where to begin
first of all
929 billion is not two-thirds of 1.7
trillion it's a little more than half
about 55 give or take which is
considerably less than two-thirds
if women are having trouble getting into
college i think we just discovered why
except in fact they aren't having
trouble getting into college women get
into college more often than men they
account for almost 60 percent of
university enrollment if they also have
the lion's share of debt that would
explain why
more women in college equals more women
with college debt pretty logical
but
60 enrollment against 55 of debt
actually means that each individual
woman on average is carrying less of the
debt burden than each individual man
men are the ones paying more than their
fair share if that's how you want to
look at it
although it's not how you ought to look
at it because the only share that each
should pay is the share they agreed to
pay when they willingly took out their
loans
does that make it a fair share
probably not
i mean not fair in any kind of
objectively ethical sense
the fact is that most people agree to
pay way too much for an education that's
worth way too little
if you spent six figures on a degree
in a queer art history or whatever
thinking that it would somehow pay
itself back in five years given the
overwhelming market demand for queer art
historians i can't say that you paid a
fair price price
the fair price would have been zero
dollars
which is quite a bit less than what
you're on the hook for
but it's still your debt
it isn't anybody else's it's yours
so all this talk about relief and
forgiveness it obscures the point the
government cannot snap its mighty
fingers and make the debt go away that's
not going to happen
no plan has been presented that would
that would or could accomplish such a
thing
somebody has to pay your debts
the debt you agreed to
while purchasing the product you wanted
and will keep
has to be paid
the only question is this who should pay
it you or someone else
i don't see how you could offer any
sound argument for the latter even if
you can convince me that the debt is
unfair and predatory and you were taken
advantage of
i might agree with all of that but it
still seems clear that the fairest of
the unfair remedies is for the person
who took out the loan to pay it
because if it's unfair that you have to
pay your loans it's certainly many times
more unfair that i should have to pay
your loans or anybody else
besides whatever possible argument could
be made for loan forgiveness
would clearly apply just as much to any
other form of debt mortgage car credit
card etc
if you're struggling with student debt
and you're handed a get out of jail free
card and i didn't go to college but i'm
struggling to pay my mortgage
should i not be offered the same deal
if your debt is a public emergency why
isn't my debt also a public emergency
now it's true that i can file for
bankruptcy but bankruptcy isn't free and
it ain't fun
and i'm probably gonna lose a lot of my
stuff in the process you don't have to
declare bankruptcy under any student
loan forgiveness plan i've seen
why should i have to take that step what
makes you special
what happened to equality under the law
in fact you know i really can't take any
loan forgiveness plan seriously that
doesn't require at a minimum
the college grad who wants forgiveness
must declare bankruptcy
and also forfeit their college degree
nobody can take away what they learned
especially because most of them didn't
learn anything
but the degree can be rescinded and that
should be a necessary part of so-called
forgiveness you didn't pay for it you
got to give it back
call it a refund instead of forgiveness
now i still wouldn't support even that
plan but it's at least a serious plan
and makes some attempt at being fair
but this is all academic pun intended
the feminists over at the women's march
aren't making a case for student loan
forgiveness they're making a case for
gender justice whatever that is
only because they didn't pay attention
in any of their math classes they don't
realize that the gender disparity on
this issue as with most other issues
cuts in their favor
so they're wrong about women being
specially victimized by student loans
and they're wrong about the student loan
issue in general they're wrong in every
way from every angle
other than that ladies great point also
you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
vladowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire
on today's episode the white house
sanctions russia for invading ukraine
biden narrows his list of supreme court
nominees and washington state's
controversial school policies on gender
identity join us and get the facts first
on the news you need to know with our
show morning wire